hello grammarians and hello Paige hi
David so today we're going to talk about
the three different ways to end a
sentence this is what we call a terminal
punctuation of English page what are
those three ways so the first is a
period okay and then exclamation point
boom and a question mark hmmmm a period
is just sort of the standard ending to a
sentence sure right it's it goes at the
end of I think most sentences I would
say that all of the sentences that we
have spoken so far would probably end in
periods so what's a good example
sentence that we could use a period at
the end of my mom ate a cookie so that's
just sort of a straight up regular ol
sentence yeah just a standard
declaration of a fact exactly this is a
thing that is true my mom ate a cookie
yes cool and then we just put this this
period there to say that's the end of
the thought end of line
so then what what is what is an
exclamation point for like what would we
use that for yeah so an exclamation
point is pretty much if someone is
excited about what they're saying okay I
think so if I were to say I'm gonna eat
so much candy when I get home I think
that was probably an exclamation sure
and ends in an exclamation point but
it's not just like good excitement
either right it's not just like whew
this is awesome
totally there can be you know anger like
go to your room right or like fear if
you said ah yes exactly we have a period
which tell this all-purpose terminal
punctuation you can just say a regular
declarative sentence here is a fact my
mom ate a cookie or you can use
exclamation points to demonstrate
excitement or strong emotion whether
good or bad so like an interjection like
uh or or a command like go to your room
or if you're super excited I'm gonna eat
so much candy what is this thing used
for mm-hmm well I think that was a
perfect example look at what that thing
is used for that is a question mark
which goes at the end of a question so
it basically just signifies I don't I
don't know the answer to this thing and
I would like an answer to it please so
okay so Paige what's an example question
that we could throw out using using a
question mark how about is this edible
that's the eternal question I ask myself
that every day
okay so we have we have periods just
statement of facts exclamations
expressions of strong emotion or
question marks which ask a question I
guess yeah cool thanks Paige thank you
for having me you can learn anything
Dave it out page out